Air Force planes airlifted patients from
Chile's capital to hospitals in faraway
cities while in Santiago ambulances
waited with sick patients outside
hospital emergency room entrances for up
to 10 hours tens of thousands of
santiago residents ignored calls for
social distancing as they queued for
essential goods ahead of the start of a
total lockdown something president
sebastián piñera had said would not be
necessary with the explosion of co v at
19 infections in the capital up by more
than 500 percent in two weeks dashed his
hopes of controlling contagion without
shutting down the economy if bomb of
Blenheim in Dickensian we are fully
aware of the difficulties the
restrictions and the shortages that our
lockdown mains for the Chilean families
we're going to make the utmost effort to
facilitate food medicine and other basic
services during the quarantine doubtless
madness is about receiving an emergency
shipment of ventilators at the airport
the president appealed to opponents to
unite in the face of a monumental threat
behind me is the entrance to Santiago's
general cemetery inside grave diggers
have been working around the clock in
order to meet and in fact surpass their
yearly quota of tombs in order to be
prepared for the worst but many people
believe it shouldn't have come to this
so soon
the government had boasted that Chile
was doing better than its neighbors
ignoring earlier pleas from doctors and
mayor's like Rodolfo Carter to declare a
total lockdown before infections got out
of control
Gemma Casey look on we have to say it
very clearly without panicking that
these next two weeks are going to be the
hardest weeks in the history of Chile
since the 1973 coup we are going to have
dead people we are going to have hurt
families police will be on the lookout
not just for those who violate the
quarantine but for traffickers who are
using delivery services which are
allowed to circulate as the perfect
cover for distributing illegal drugs
Chile's anti-narcotics squads have
already made more than 200 arrests
multisim they misuse well-known brands
of delivery services to deliver drugs
instead of food or medicine
why because a policeman probably won't
suspect a delivery man on a bicycle
that's why we're cyber patrolling the
social networks to try and identify the
traffickers the battle to stop people
from violating or abusing the quarantine
is on now the chili is doing what most
agree is the right thing though not
necessarily soon enough you see in human
al Jazeera Santiago Boris van der spec
is the founder of Chile today an online
independent news platform he joins us
now live from the Capitol santiago good
to have you with us how do people there
feel about this lockdown well a large
part of the people of Santiago Seoul is
coming because in the last couple of
weeks just like Lucia said the numbers
have been increasing very rapidly
compared with the weeks before and
especially in the more middle class or
even say lower income parts of Santiago
the outbreak has been so severe that
extreme measures had to be taken so you
see that especially in the parts where
the corona virus has struck people
understand the measure what's behind
this this rise over the last two weeks
when the country had appeared to be
doing so well in its fight against curve
in nineteen so the corona virus outbreak
in shyla has been a bit of this
story of entire Latin America it's a
it's an inequality thing it came in to
Chile to the health to the wealthier
parts of Santiago where people have
private clinics where they can do their
guarantee at their houses but now it
went to the lower-income parts of
Santiago where people live closer
together lots of people active in
informal sector we need to get to work
to put food on the table and also the
public health care system there has
totally collapsed in the last couple of
weeks so it's just a complete different
situation at the moment it's like a
different pandemic than the outbreak
that we saw before and it's the
government able to help financially
those who are unable to go out and work
and put food on the table so recently
the government approved the emergency
bill for those work in the informal
sector and Gina which is like 30 percent
of the people but the amount of money
that the government is giving to these
people is around $100 a month it's just
not enough to cover it's probably gonna
be a rise apart from the lot of health
dangers here in the city also a big
problem in the rise of poverty that
we'll be seeing in the next couple of
months how long will this lockdown last
and will people abide by it so the
lockdown originally they said it will
last for one week
health experts internationally say a
lockdown should at least last two weeks
but there are people in the more rich
parts of Santiago who left actually
before the lockdown started tonight at
10 p.m. - their second homes outside
near the coast so they are leaving and
during the quarantine also like Lucia
said it's very very we'll see especially
in those lower-income parts of Santiago
if people will really abide the rules
imposed by the government good stops
here so many thanks indeed Boris vendors
back there in Santiago no problem